now after days of dodging and denial
this morning the Deputy Prime Minister
finally acknowledged formal complaints
about his misconduct but his letter
contains no hint of admission or apology
this is anti-bullying
[Applause]
this this is anti-bullying week will he
apologize
[Applause]
look in terms of the economic challenges
which are Global caused by covert and
the war in Ukraine we've got a plan to
grip inflation balance the books and
drive economic growth if we listen to
The Honorable lady debt would go up
unemployment will go up and working
briefings would pay the price she asked
she asked she asked about the complaints
I received notification this morning I
immediately asked the Prime Minister set
up an independent uh inquiry into them
I'm confident I pay professionally
throughout but of course I will engage
thoroughly and look forward Mr Speaker
may I say look forward to transparently
addressing any claims that have been
made Andrew
so Mr Speaker let me get the straight
imandan investigation into himself
because the prime minister is too weak
to get a grip yeah prime minister in
office less than a month with a
disgraced cabinet minister resigned with
his good wishes the Home Secretary who
breached the ministerial code and risked
National Security still clings on and
now the Prime Minister defends his
Deputy whose Behavior has been described
as abrasive controlling and demeaning
with junior staff Mr Speaker two scared
to even enter his office and that's
without mentioning the flying Tomatoes
the Deputy Prime Minister knows his
behavior is unacceptable so what's he
still doing here
let me prime minister Mr Speaker I'm
here and happy to address any specific
point she wishes to make uh that that
well that never happened uh she says
from a sedentary position and I will
thoroughly rebut and refute any of the
claims that be made she hasn't in fact
she hasn't in fact put a specific point
to me if she wishes to do so and this is
her opportunity I'd be very glad to
address it Angela Reyna
Mr speaker
thank you Angela Ray right thank you Mr
Speaker maybe he just doesn't think
there's a problem or maybe suggesting
that civil servants are liars
now he's reportedly banned from meeting
junior staff without supervision while
we await and inquiry the Prime Minister
hasn't even instigated from a watchdog
he hasn't even appointed in in prime
minister's letter he did not say how and
when this will be investigated or by who
no ethics no integrity and no mandate
and still no ethics advisor so when will
they appoint an independent ethics
advisor and drain the swamp
memory prime minister Mr Speaker the
recruitment of the new ethics advisor is
already underway and taking and taking
place at place but may I say Mr Speaker
there's a reason that she's come to this
Matchbox with her usual mix of Bluster
and mud slinging it's because they don't
have a plan
[Applause]